[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
لماذا تهربوا عشرات الاسر السوريه من جنه
استقرار الاسد كما يصفها مؤيد النظام الى
جحيم المعارضه التي يتهممها بالخيانه
والعماله
في موسكو وفيران
لكن في المقابل اليس العالم كله مازوما من
شرقيه لغربه الا تعاني دول عربيه اخرى
اكثر مما يعاني منه السوريون وهي لم تاخذ
حروبا ولم تتعرض لحصار الم تتهاوى العملات
في بلدان الاخرى باكثر مما تهاوت به
الليره السوريه وماذا بوسع حلفاء الاسد اي
يفعل وهم يعانون تحت اقصى انواع العقوبات
في التاريخ
من برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس ورحب بضيفين
الاكاديمي السوري الدكتور يحيى العريضي
ومن باريس وارحب ايضا بالكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من دمشق غسان يوسف
ابدا النقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد وارحب مره اخرى بضيفيه
من باريس الدكتور يحيى العريديه الاكاديمي
السوري ومن دمشق الكاتب الصحفي غسان يوسف
وابدا بعد معك استاذ غسان يوسف يعني عاده
الانظمه الاستبداد التي تصادر الحريات
يكون ذلك في مقابل ان توفر العيش الكريم
ولقمه العيش اذا فشل اي نظام
يتخذوا الاستبداد منهجا في ذلك هل تبقى له
اي شرعيه حتى عندما
تحياتي لك استاذ زين والديك الكريم
والاستاذه المشاهدين
يعني طبعا من الاجحاف انه يحمل يعني
الدوله السوريه كل ما وصل اليه الوضع الان
في سوريا وانت تعرف يعني بان يعني مصيبه
سوريا هي مع الولايات المتحده والعقوبات
التي يعني فرضتها الولايات المتحده
العقوبات ليست جديده انا اقول لك ولكن
يعني لم تكن بهذه القسوه يعني في عام 1979
كانه كان هناك عقوبات امريكيه على سوريا
واتهمت سوريا بدعم الارهاب ايضا هذه
العقوبات في عام 1986 ومن ثم في 2003 يعني
قانون محاسبه سوريا
اشتدت هذه العقوبات طبعا في عام 2011 وكان
كل شهر تفرض عقوبات امريكيه على سوريا
وايضا او عزه الولايات المتحده للاتحاد
الاوروبي بان يقوم قرض عقوباتها وتسمى
مانع استيراد النقد من سوريا وقام الاتحاد
الاوروبي بقاره عقوبات على سوريا وفي عام
يعني همم داعش على النفط السوري وكان ينتج
كان اكس سوريا كانت تنتج 385 الف برميل في
اليوم
ويعني كانت تنتج من القمح وليت ثلاثه
مليون طن ثانويه ولن تكن سوريا يعني دوله
فقيره ولا في حاجه لاحد ولكن يعني سرقه
هذه الموارد السوريه ايضا العقوبات
المتتاليه سواء احنا يعني ليس همم علينا
عقبات من الامم المتحده وان العقوبات ان
العقوبات هي من الولايات المتحده ومن همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ايضا كان هناك يعني مقاطعه من دول الجوار
العربي يعني وخصوصا الدول العربيه التي
تعرف قرارات الجامعه العربيه وتجميد عضويه
سوريا في الجامعه العربيه
لكن المصيبه الكبرى متى حصلت
في عام 2019 عندما قام الولايات المتحده
لسن قانون قيصر وبدا العمل به في حزيران
يونيو 2020 يعني كانت الليره السوريه
مقابل الدولار في قبل هذا القانون حوالي
440 ليره سوريه او 5
الى 700 ومن ثم توالت الانهيارات
وساذكرك بما قاله همم يعني المبعوث
الامريكي السابق الى سوريا يعني هذا اللص
الذي قال همم لن نسمح همم سوريا اولا بان
سيدنا نفقها وايضا يعني دونالد ترامب
عندما
تذكر يعني ما قال دونالد ترامب قال نحن
همم سنبقى في سوريا وهمم ويكيب زاويل
وويلتين ذا اوويل يعني نحن سنحتفظ
وايضا مالك اسبر وزير الدفاع قال لن تسمح
للدوله السوريه من هذا النفط في حين قال
المبعوث الامريكي السابق همم يعني غير
زياده افريقيه قال هذه قرصنه
والنفط السوري هو الذي الدوله السوريه
تطبيق قانون قيصر يعني قانون قيصر لا
يستهدي فقط الدوله السوريه تستهدف سوريا
واصدقاء سوريا الذين يتعاملون معها
كاروسيا وايران والصين وجيران سوريا يعني
همم
استاذ غسان انت ذكرت ثلاثه اسباب في
الواقع
الازمه التي يعيشها السوريون الان هذه
الاسباب تمتد من عام 79
حتى عام 2020 2019 2020 هي العقوبات سبب
السبب الاخر المقاطعه العربيه وقد راينا
انها بدات تتهاوى هذه المقاطعه
وسرقت النفط كل هذه اسباب قديمه ما الذي
يجعل الازمه بهذه الشده الان
فقط لاقول لك هي ليست قديمه هي يعني قلت
لك اصبحت شديده وقويه منذ توقيع قانون
قيصر لماذا لان قانون قيصر العقوبات على
الشركات التي تتعامل مع الحكومه
الحاليه غير مسئوله
القانون قيصر كان الهدف منه همم هو
يعني اولا تجفيف الدولار والعمله الصعبه
في سوريا لانه فرضت عقوبات على البنك
المركزي وبالتالي لا تستطيع البنوك
الموجوده في سوريا التعامل مع البنك
المركزي وهناك بنوب كثيره اغلقت ومن ثم
انسحبت ايضا فرضت عقوبات على لبنان على
الشركات التي تتعامل مع سوريا
اذا العقوبات هي السبب هذا هو رايك
الى هذا الوضع وخصوصا يعني يتذكر يعني حتى
2019 كان الوضع السوري مقبولا وكانت
الليره السوريه مقابل الدولار مقبوله ولكن
عندما
نقول عن هذا الواضح فرض عليه والنظام لا
مسؤوليه له عن هذا الوطن دكتور يحيى
العريضي
[موسيقى]
وكل شيء الدوله
يعني انت تقول ان كل هذا فعل عوامل خارجيه
لا توجد عوامل داخليه
يا يا استاذ زيد انا بالنسبه لي والله
يعني
ذكرت سببا واحدا داخليا هل هنالك اي
مسؤوليه للحكومه عن ذلك للنظام عن ذلك ولا
لا توجد مسؤوليه
اقول لك الحكومات لم تتغير والنظام لم
يتغير يعني قبل 2011 كان الرئيس هو نفسه
كان الحزب الحزب البعث موجود لم يعني لم
تتغير النظاره
تعمل حسب الامكانيات المتوفره لكن عندما
تكون هذه الامكانيات قد يعني وصلت الى
الحضيض بسبب العقوبات ستصرف يعني ما هو
متوفي لذلك انا من جهته لا احمل الحكومه
همم ما وصلت اليه الاوضاع ولكن اقول لك
عندما تكون اخرى يكون هناك حتى لو كان
هناك لا يعني تتضح الامور وتصبح في هذه
النظر الاخرى من الدكتور يحيى العريضي من
باريس دكتور يحيى
لك استاذ زايد اهلا وسهلا
وتحيه للضيف
ولمتابعين جزيره
وبعيدا عن الحاله المواجهاتيه بل كانسان
السوري بقي على قيد الحياه
صدفه رغم التهديدات كثيره
ويريد لبلده ان يعود الى الحياه ليس اكثر
من ذلك
الوضع الحالي
فيها قهر
وفقر وجع
وضياع وحزن وجع
وخوف ورعب
في بلد
وبعثر
تحت الاحتلال
السلطه اجراميه
منفصل عن الواقع
تنتحر الكذب
خطه مستبده اهتزازيه
دمرت البلد
اعتقلت شبابه
شردت شعبه استخدمت الاسلحه المحرمه الناس
لا تتعلق بالازمه الاقتصاديه انا اريد ان
اتحدث عن الازمه الاقتصاديه
ضيفنا من دمشق يقول انه قانون قيصر
والعقوبات المتتاليه ثم
سرقه النفط السوري من قبل داعش والان كما
يقول من قبل
التحالف الدولي والولايات المتحده كما
يقول
وايضا المقاطعه العربيه كل هذه اسباب
خارجيه لا توجد اسباب داخليه لهذه العظم
الواقع الحالي القائم الذي يعترف به كل
انسان سوري
باستثناء من هو منفصل عن الواقع
وتحديدا هذه المنظومه الاستبداديه
المنفصله عن الواقع التي لا تسمح بان تنام
باي شيء حدث وانت اصريت على ضيفك بان
ربما يضع شيء من الملامه
والمسؤوليه على تلك المنظومه
ولكنه للاسف ابا
ااه
واتمنى على الاستاذ غسان ان
يصحى قليلا
ويزيح هذه القمامه
عن عن عن اعينه ويرى الامور بحقيقتها
عندما يصبح في بلد الحياه والموت سيان ليس
بسبب عقوبات العقوبات بالنسبه لقيصر
تحديدا تلك المنظومه ومن يتعامل معها
هذا المشكله من جانب الاخر هي لم لم تمنع
على الاطلاق
مسالتي الغذاء والدواء
وعمليا
من اوصل الى هذه الحاله هو الحاله استخدم
كلمه علميه الفجعنه الموجوده عند هذه
السلطه الاستبداديه الانانيه التي تؤمن
بالكل او لا شيء او الاسد او لا احد او
الاسد او نحرق البلد الممتحنه لاستبداد
التي يغيب فيها القانون الخوف هو السائد
والارهاب والارهاب والارهاب الدوله تحديدا
وهذه الامور ليست بجديده على الاطلاق لم
تاتي من عام
1997 او 79 اتت قديما هي مبنيه على هذا
الاساس وهناك اسباب سياسيه واقتصاديه
واجتماعيه وثقافيه وتربويه استطيع ان افصل
بها تماما
موضوع النقاش موضوع النقاش هو الازمه
الحاليه ما سببها
ذكر اسباب وق ادله همم انت تقول النظام ما
مسؤوليه النظام اشرح لي كيف يمكن لون
النظام على ازمه اقتصاديه همم تمسك بي
يعني تلابيب العالم كلي وليس فقط سوريا
قانون قيصر
ان
همم يقاطع هذه المنظومه ومن يتعامل معها
وساحه جانبا مساله الغذاء ومساله الدواء
بشكل اساسي هذه ليست ملموسه
والمساعدات تاتي من جانب الاخر هو النظام
نفسه استغل هذا القانون كي يبرر فشله كي
يبرر فساده كي يبرر تسلطه على الناس
وابتزازه لهم واخذ سوريه رهينه كي يستمر
لتلك الدعايه حول المؤامره الدوليه التي
عسى حراك الشعب السوري من اجل
الحريه
لهذا الامر ببساطه قال ان هناك مؤامره على
سوريه مؤامره على النظام لماذا لم انه
مقاومه وممنعه ويريد ان يحرر فلسطين اليوم
نرى عكس ذلك تماما كل ذلك استخدم كذليعه
لقمع الشعر
لاستمرار الفساد
واستمرت تلك الذريعه كل هذا الوقت ولا
تزال للاسف مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه عمليا
في سوريا هناك مواد الحاله السياسيه هناك
حزب واحد يتحكم بالامور
دكتور
من مصلحه النظام ان يوفر الامن الغذائي
لمن هم تحت سيطرته
انت تقول انه فاشل اسالك لماذا فشل في
رايك
لانه فعليا يهتم بشكل اساسي
بذاته فقط
يكون هو وهو يستمر هو او لا تكون ولا
تستمر سوريا
بالنسبه للنفط الذي يتم التحدث عنه هو
الذي تسيطر عليه داعش او او
امريكا الان
الان النفط ليس امرا مستجدا في سوريا
النفط منذ خمسه عقود في سوريا لكن موارد
هذا النفط تذهب الى حسابات خاصه
المساله ليست ليست طارئه
امر اخر الان ماذا يحدث في في دمشق يتم
السيطره على هؤلاء ما بقي من تجار
وابتزازهم واخذ اموالهم
المكتب السري او اشياء من هذا القبيل هي
التي تتحكم بهذه الامور الان
اضافه الى حاله الاتزان نحن لدينا معتقلين
بعشرات وبئات الالاف ربما الان ماذا يحدث
لاهلهم
شو وابتزازا حتى يعرفوا معلومه بسيطه عن
ابنائهم اضافه الى كل الدمار الذي حدث ان
اتحدث في بدايه حديثي عن تلك الاوضاع
المؤلمه التي لا يتحملها بشر عندها عندها
هؤلاء البشر استوى الموت مع الحياه لا
يوجد كهرباء لا يوجد همم وقود لا يوجد
امان لا يوجد اي شيء من مقومات
ان تبقى حيا همم الامر الاساسي بالنسبه
للانسان السوري في هذا الوطن الذي ليس لها
غيره ان يخرج من هذا المكان
وهذا ما حدث بالفعل عشرات الاسر اللاجئت
الى مناطق المعارضه كثير من الشباب
يركبوا الموت قوارب الموت في البحر هربا
من مناطق النظام اعود الى ضيفنا من دمشق
غسان يوسف ومع ذلك يعني هنالك اتهامات
للنظام بانه اصبح اكبر تاجر كبتاجون اكبر
تاجر مخدرات ربما في الشرق الاوسط وفي
اكثر من الشرق الاوسط لان الاهتمام ليس
بتوفير لقبه العيش للمواطن الاهتمام كما
يقول ضيفنا من باريس هو الاثراء الشخصي
للمحسوبين على النظام كيف ترد على ذلك
استاذ زين يعني انا ساعلق على ثلاث الاولى
يقول لي يعني انزع هذه الغشاوه انا اقول
له يعني كنت دكتور انت في التلفزيون
السوري وكنت مديرا ومن ثم عميد لكليه
الاعلام وكنت يعني ااا تعيش في هذه
المنظومه
وبحاله راقيه همم ثم همم حتى 2011 كانت
الامور في سوريا همم جيده بالنسبه لمقوله
الاسد او نحرق البلد طبعا يعني هذه مقوله
همم روجتها المعارضه ومن مصلحتها ان تقال
هذه العباره لان هذه العباده تسيء للدوله
السوريه هذا جهه اخرى لنا عود الى
الوضع الاقتصادي
وكيف يعني مثلا
يوميا يسرق حوالي 66 الف برميل همم من
سوريا وتهرب الى العراق
خسائر الدوله السوريه يعني تسول هذا الرقم
المهول الاستاذ زين حوالين 110 او 111,000
مليار دولار يعني هذه خسرتها الدوله
السوريه خلال هذه الحرب يعني لاحظنا هذه
لان هذه
معطيات وفقا لاي مصادر مليار هذه
لا هذا بيان وزاره الخارجيه السوريه همم
ايضا لاحظ يعني لان مثلا همم
الضيف لم يذكر ابدا ان هناك اطراف اخرى
يعني لديك مثلا في سوريا همم حواليه 136
حسب مركز ابحاث فيريل بينما اللبن المتحده
قوله قالت بان 40 الف مقاتل اجنبي دخلوا
الى سوريا وقاتله معه النصره وداعش
والمنظمات الارهابيه الاخرى
وقتله من الشعب السوري ما قتل همم يعني
اخته واخته ولكن هذا لم يذكره احد ولا
يتذكره المعارضه همم ايضا بالنسبه لحضرتك
انت قلت انه تذهب الى الناس تذهب الى
مناطق المعارضه قانون قيصر استثنا منطقتين
من تطبيق قانون قيصر هما الشمال الشرقي
التي تسيطر عليه فساد
وتحت له الولايات المتحده والشمال الغربي
الذي تحتله تركيا وتسيطر همم اللي ما يسمى
الجيش الوطني وجبهه النصره اذا المشكله هي
في الولايات المتحده وفي توزيع يعني الظنم
والقهر همم يعني اذا كان هذا المشكله يعني
موجوده المشكله
يعني تم وعدهم
بالمن والسلوى
بالخبز واللبن مقابل ان يعيشوا تحت سلطه
النظام وان لا يقاوم هذا النظام بعد عشر
سنين ها هم يفرنا الى مناطق المعارضه هذه
النقطه لماذا في الرون اذا كان النظام
يوفر لكل انسان العيش الكريم قال له توفر
العيش الكريم
نعم نعم
كنت اتحدث لك يعني عندما فرد قانون قيصر
على سوريا متى يعني حدثت لازمه المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الدوله عندما نجحت
الدوله السوريه في تحرير الاراضي حوالي
70% منال الاراضي السوريه تم تحريرها
يعني ايه بسواعد الجيش العربي السوري ضد
المجموعات الارهابيه التي دعمتها يعني دول
الجوار وعلى راسها تركيا وادخلت 140,000
مقاتل اجنبي قتلوا في سوريا عندما حرر
الدوله السوريه هذه المناطق همم استعد
اللوبي السوري المعارضه الموجود في واشنطن
الاساسي يعني يعني من صاغ هذا القانون
الذي يقول لك الدكتور يحيى انه ليس هناك
يعني حصار على الغذاء والدواء لا هناك همم
دوله السوريه
ماذا عن المنظومه الامنيه التي
تاخذ كل شيء ولا تترك للناس شيئا كل هذا
غير مسؤول
لا لا مو هون الموضوع الموضوع انا بقول لك
اي حكومه بالعالم طول بالك بس خليني اكمل
فكره اي حكومي بالعالم فيها فساد لكن انا
اقول لك
فرض العقوبات على البنك المركزي وعلى
البنوك التي تتعامل معه بتهريب الاموال
الى لبنان حوالي 40 مليار ليره سوريه كانت
تجار السوريون يسحبون من هذه الاموال
ويقومون بالاستيراد عبر مرفق بيروت ومن ثم
ياتون الى سوريا بهذه البضائع قامت
الولايات المتحده بمنع سحب يعني المودعين
في البنوك اللبنانيه لماذا ليكون هناك
حصار على الدوله السوريه
لكن انت لم تذكر اي سبب داخلي حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تدخل انه الفساد يمثل جزءا من
المشكله يعني ان تقولها هل هنالك فساد
وهذا الفساد مسؤول وحتى لو بالنسبه
ولا تقول لكن
لا لا ما في حكومه بالعالم الا فيها فساد
انا معروف طيب ما مسؤوليه الفساد طيب
ما هي مسؤوليته
لا كيف بدي اجاوبك لان انا اسال انت لا
تجيب تفضل
خليني انا بدي اجاوبك بس انت ما عم تعطيني
الوقت
يجب على السؤال
الذي اساله
لن اقاطع ما هي مسؤوليه الفساد في الدوله
السوريه عن ما يجري الان
هل هي
1%10% 100%
انا قلت لك لا توجد حكومه في العالم ولا
توجد حكومه السوريه الا ويكون فيها فساد
ولكن عندما تكون هناك عقوبات كقانون قيصر
وعقوبات من دول الجوار وعقوبات على البنك
المركزي الماليه
فلان انا من من مكافحه الفساد انا عم بحكي
لك الحالي عن وصف لك يا كاتب وتعلامه
قبل ذلك فلن اريد ان اكرر الكلام دكتور
يحيى العريضي همم كما استمعت الى ضيفنا من
دمشق المساله معقده مسؤوله همم طويله
قديمه ولا يوجد في يد النظام شيء اريد ان
تقول لي اين هي النقاط التي فشل فيها
النظام في توفير ما ينبغي ان يوفره
للمواطن السوري ما هي مسؤوليه النظام قل
لي ما هي ما هو التقصير الذي حدث
بدايه يسمح لي بدقيقه واحده انا اقول انه
قال لي شخصيا كليه الاعلام وكنت من هذه
المنظومه الى اخره على الاقل يا استاذ زين
انا شفيت من هذا الامر
ويوسفني جدا ان يكون الاستاذ غسان لا زال
غاضبا في في في ذلك المستنقع وللاسف ما
زال اذا اذا استمر في حاله الانفصام عن
الواقعه
ان شاء الله تكون الامور نفسها ان شاء
الله
اتمنى ذلك وان تكون وان تكون ان تكون رايت
الامور على حقيقتها همم من جانب الاخر انا
شخصيا حاولت وانا عميد على مدار ثلاثه
اشهر
ان همم تعالج الامور او ان تقارب بالنسبه
لسوريا مع الانتفاضه الشعب السوري على
الفساد وكل وكل ما حدث ان تعالج بطريقه
سلميه لكن كما كثيرين في ان ان ان ان ان
ان ان ان احقق ذلك وهمم للاسف نحن عندما
يتم الحديث عن همم او وراء الاستاذ بسام
بانها ما قلته انه يمس الدوله انا لا
اتحدث عن دوله اسلام غسان انا اتحدث للاسف
عن اصاب وسابين لك استاذ زين ما هو ما هو
الذي تفعله هي تعني بذاتها حصرا
وبامولها ولديها مليارات موجوده في ملوك
العالم وهذا النفط الذي تسرقه امريكا الان
ولست مف- مفتونا او مظهرا بامريكا حتى
ادافع عنها على الاطلاق ولا عن تركيا ولا
عن اي جهه اخرى انا ادافع عن اي طفل سوري
عن استعاده بلد اللي يعود الى الحياه
ببساطه شديده اقول لك هذه المنظومه لو
كانت تمتلك اي ذره من الشرف او القيم او
الاخلاق لق اريد ان احافظ على هذا المكان
لانه يعني الكثير ل 23 مليون انسان هي
تعنى بحوالي 1,000 انسان على حساب 23
مليون انسان عمليا
لارى الحكومه الحكومه الحكومه اداه بنفش
واحد بتليفون واحد كلها تزول القرار بيد
جهه
معين اصاب الان تتاجر
دكتور يحيى لانه ليس منطقيا لاي نظام يعني
سمه كما تريد ان تساميه النظام
الديكتاتوري النظام غير ديكتاتوري ليس في
مصلحه اي نظام على وجه الارض ان يجوع
الناس الذين يحكموهم
فلماذا يجوع الناس في مناطق النظام باكثر
مما يرجعون حتى في مناطق المعارضه عندما
عندما
اريد ان اعرف ما هي المشكله
او مدمرها الاسد او نحرق البلد اخذت
الجواب من ذلك من من تلك العباره من ذلك
الشعار الامور بترميزها الامور رموزها
ببساطه شديده الان عندما يكون هناك
مسؤوليه
تصور لست مغرما بمكرون اطلاقا لكن عندما
ينزل الى الملعب الى الملعب
ويواسي ذلك الشاب الذي شعر بالانكسار هذا
موقف طيب انساني لم يشعر السوريون على
الاطلاق بلحظه مثل هذه لم يشعر السوريون
من هذه المنظومه باي تعاطف باي اعتراف
الواقع باي خطا انت تحاول اقصى جهدك لتقول
لضيفك بان يقول هناك خطا معين هو لا يقول
هو اسباب اخرى خارجيه خارجيه تمام
وقانون قيصر ظالم هنقول كابتن قوم ظالم
وكل القوانين ظالمه لكن ماذا اتصرف انا
انا اريد لبلدي ان يعود للحياه ليس منطقيا
ان تكون دوله ما تريدنا شعبها ان يجوع لكن
هي تؤمن بان جوع كل
به الامر يطالب الجميع ومن هنا عمليا
علينا ان نصحى
نصحى جميعا
ونلتف ونكون كلمه واحده لاستعاده بلدنا
بلدنا مستباح ببساطه شديده من خمسه قوه هي
قوه الاحتلال الروسيه قوه الاحتلال
الايرانيه
اثراء قوه الاحتلال تركيا لاقولها حتى لا
يقول لي انتم مع الاتراك لا انا لا اريد
اجنبيه على هذه الارض اريد سوريه لكن هذه
المنظومه تكون هي السبب الاساسي لوجوده
[موسيقى]
هذا البلد الموجوع الذي يعاني من الفقر
ومن العذاب والانتحار موجود والظل موجود
وبقايا الاخرين
اي اقتصاد موجود الان
حينما تكون هنالك ازمه يعني الناس اعتدوا
على الرئيس السوري يحدثهم بالساعات في غير
اوقات الازمات فما باله في وقت الازمه لا
يتحدث مع المواطن ولا يشرح له ولا يزوره
حتى ضيفنا ذكر مكرونه الذي نزل الى الملعب
لوسي
فما بالك بتسعه ملايين سوري لا يجدون
الخبز بعضهم يهرب لانه يقول انه لم ياكل
خبزا منذ شهرين
سؤال ليه
هذه الكلمات التي يقولها الدكتور يحيى
يعني هو لم يذكر الاحتلال الامريكي هذا
الكلام لانه وصل لاعب الرئيس الاسد كان
يتواجد بين الناس وفي المطاعم ويتواجد في
الحقول وكان يحمل ويزرع الشجر
الاخبار الوارده
يعني لا تفضل
طيب يعني انا اقول لك يعني الاحتلال
الامريكي الذي هو السبب والذي يسرق النفط
والذي يحرق القمر والذي استولى على سنوات
البلد لم يذكره الضيف ايضا ايضا اعتقد بان
انت واحد حتى لو نضيع الوقت في في الرد
على اسئله غير موجوده لانه هذا سؤال غير
موجود لانه الضيف قال لا اريد قدما اجنبيه
على ارض سوريه فهذا انتهى هذا الموضوع
انتهى انا سالتك عن الرئيس يعني الذي كان
يخطب في الناس بالساعات لماذا لا يظهر
الان لماذا لا يقول لهم لماذا انتم جائعون
لماذا لا يشرح لهم الاسباب
من هذا السؤال
الموضوع الموضوع
الاساسي الذي يعني انت وضيفك لا تريد ان
تتكلم عنه تكلم عنه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وقال انا سالتقي بالرئيس الاسد
وسيترك المعارضه وستذهب المعارضه الى
الجحيم وايضا يعني ستعود هذه المناطق التي
تستولي عليها القوات التركيه الى الدوله
السوريه وسيكون هناك الجميع تخلى عن
المعارضه المنفصله عن الواقع التي ليس لها
علاقه بالواقع يعني لا تريد ان تعتني في
العقوبات الدوليه لا تريد ان تعتني بقانون
قيصر لا تريد ان تعترف بالعقبات على البنك
المركزي لا تريد ان تعترف بان يعني هذه
القوانين التي تصدر يوميا الولاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن الولايات المتحده هدفوها همم
الشعب السوري يعني هل انا اقول لك عندما
تفر العقوبات على الدوله يعني هل الشعب
الذي يعيش في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
الدوله لن يتاثر يعني هذا هذا نوع من
الازوازيه والظلم والحقاره التي تستخدمها
الولايات المتحده والذي يرددها المعارضون
والذين لا يذكرون لا جبهه النصره ولا داعش
ولا ما يسمى الجيش الوطني الذي جميعه يعني
عناصره ارهابيه وتحمل السلاح وتقاتل
الدوله ولا يريد ان يذكروا البيكيكي ولا
يريدون ان يذكروا فسد ابدا كل هذا الشيء
كله لا يذكرونه فقط يذكرون بان النظام
والنظام والدوله والحكومه والفساد وغير
ذلك اذا كان اذا كان هم الولايات المتحده
هو تجفيف كل البنوك السوريه والغرب كل
العقوبات على البنوك اللبنانيه التي
تتعامل مع الدوله السوريه وكل الدول وكل
الدول الصديقه فكيف لك يعني ان تتحرك يعني
اذا
بناتها بنات صوره حول شخص معين هل تريد له
ان ينط عن السور مثلا هذا هذا
الذي تصلمه
الاعلام العربي ومن المعارضه ومن كل الدول
التي قطعتنا تصور يعني الامارات العربيه
المتحده قال لفت برفع ام قيصر الملك
الاردن ذهب الى الولايات المتحده ليقول
للرئيس بعد بان قانون قيصر همم يعني هذا
القانون يضايقنا ان احنا كا اردنيين لا
نريد ان نعترف بهذا الشيء المعارضه لا
تريد ان تعترف بهذا الشيء لماذا لانها فقط
يعني عدوها هو النظام وعدوها يعني كان
النظام موجود
لا في لا في مقدمه البرنامج ولا في اسئلتي
لم اذكر شيئا عن المعارضه
لانه يتحدث عن الازمه داخل المناطق النظام
السوري ونريد ان نعرف اسبابها حتى يستفيد
المشاهد وانت اثرت نقطه نقطه نقطه
بشكل جيد لكن انا اريد ان اسالك عن اصدقاء
النظام السوري عن اصدقاء لانه قضيه
المعارضه ناقشناها مرارا ناقشت في هذا
البرنامج مرارا نقشت في كل البرامج تقريبا
لكن فيما يتعلق بهذه الازمه تحديدا حتى لا
يتوه منا النقاش همم
الرئيس ال- ال- النظام السوري تقول انه
محاصر صحيح لكن له اصدقاء له اصدقاء في في
موسكو وله اصدقاء ايضا في طيران لماذا لم
يخفوا لنجدته من هذه الازمه التي يعاني
منها
اليوم العقوبات الامريكيه تشمل الاصدقاء
الدوله السوريه وهم روسيا الصين ايران
يعني تعرف حتى الولايات المتحده على الصين
يعني حتى ناقلات الناصره التي تاتي الى
سوريا تحتاجها في ميناء جبل طارق وفي قناه
السويس وفي اليونان وفي كل مكان يلاحقون
القوايا قوافل النفط الايرانيه وايضا يعني
روسيا عندما تقدم همم مساعده الى سوريا
تكون دائما همم يعني ملاحقه ومحاصره
ومهدده شركات التي تتعامل مع الدوله
السوريه يعني هذا لا يؤخذ بالحسبان اذا
كان حتى الافراد حتى الافراد الذين
يتعاملون مع الدوله السوريه يلاحقون ويخلط
عليها منع السفر وتجنيد اصولهم وهناك
حوالي 500 شخصيه معاقبه لانها تتعامل مع
الدوله السوريه الا يؤثر هذا على الشعب
السوري الا يؤثر على الشعب الذي يعيش ضمن
الدوله السوريه كل هذا نريد ان نتجاوزه
ونقول له امن النظام كل هذا دكتور يحل
عندي كيف ترد على ذلك حتى اصدقائي النظام
محاصرون ما الذي يمكن فعله يعني هذه ثاني
اذكر لك فقط انه العملات في العالم العربي
تهاوت هي الاخرى امام الدولار الامريكي
يذكر الجنيه المصري يذكر الليره اللبنانيه
حتى جوار الشمال تركيا الليره التركيه
هنالك ازمه يعاني منها المحاصرون وغير
المحاصرين فمن باب اولى ان يكون المحاصرون
يعانون اكثر وهذا ما يحدث داخل المناطق
النظام السوري كيف ترد على هذه النقطه
استاذ زين ملعون ابو امريكا
امريكا هذه لو كانت فعليا
تهتم بالشعب السوري اذا كانت باتصال
البسيط السوريه
حقيقه ثابته لا يستطيع ضيفك ان يقر بها
لان هذه المنظومه فعليه
باقيه بمفعول امريكيا اسرائيلي
وهذه حقيقه يجب ان يعرفها الله عليك
تتصرف تحت يافطه تحرير الجولان
صيانه وحده البلد
سياده البلد تاسيس وضع المواطن حمايه
المواطن حمايه الحدود النهوض بالحياه
السوريه
ليس هناك اي مبرر لاستمرار هذه المنظومه
الاستبداديه واستعداد وقتل 23 مليون انسان
سوري
وتدمير بلدهم وتفتيته
هذا هو الوضع القائم لكن هذه حقيقه لا
يستطيع لا غسان ولم يغسان ولا اي حدا على
ضفه الاخرى ان يقولها المصير سيكون
بالنسبه له
وباقي مرعب ومن هنا اعتقد انني امتلك
الحريه تقريبا ان نتحدث بهذا الامر لكنه
لا يستطيع اتحدث في ذلك ومن هنا قلت لك
ارجو ان تعفيه من ذلك السؤال من هنا اعتقد
انني امد يدي له ولاي جهه
المساله
اذا الدكتور انا بكره بدي ندل لك ايدي
ماشي شكرا المساله بسيطه هي
اينما كنت على اي ضيفه كنت اريد انقاذ هذا
البلد
والوباء القائم والمبرر لوجود الاحتلالات
والمبرر لوجود الفقر
هو هذه المنظومه الاستبداديه التي تسميها
بالدوله وليست بدوله على الاطلاق ان ما هي
عصابه تتاجر بالكبتاجون
واستغل الناس وتاخذهم
رهينه وتعطي مبررات لبوتين رغم حربه في
اوكرانيا بان يستمر بابتزاز سوريا وايران
التي اتت تحت يا خطات مختلفه بالحمايه
مراقد وغيرها ذكرت مليشيات المليشيات هي
التي ذبحت السوريين داعش داعش النظام هو
الذي اخذها الى امك مختلفه وهو له علاقه
معها مباشره والقاعده وجودها في ايران
لا تعت
رفون الكلى طيب
استاذ غسان ساعيد عليك السؤال الذي طرحته
في مقدمه هذا البرنامج يعني النظام ناجح
جدا ناجح جدا في حفظ الامن ناجح جدا في
تكميم الافواه ناجح جدا في السيطره
والبقاء طيله هذه المدراغمه العقوبات و
رغم كل شيء
ناجح جدا لكن لماذا هو فاشل جدا فيما
يتعلق بالناس فيما يتعلق بحياتهم فيما
يتعلق بالخبز فيما يتعلق بالمحروقات فيما
يتعلق بهذه الاشياء لو كان النظام يعمل
على هذه الاشياء مثل ما يعمل على حفظ
الامن او على الاقل قمع الناس لربما كان
صادفه النجاح لانه سيكون عمل عمل الخير
هذا
استاذ زين يعني انا اتمنى
يذهب الحديث الى مكان اخر وان يكون هناك
مساحه
للحوار والنقاش وان تعطيني الوقت الكافي
لاجيبك انا اقول لك اليوم يعني عندما نجحت
الدوله السوريه في تحرير هذه الاراضي عامه
الولايات المتحده ومن يدور في فلكها يعني
مثلا هل تنكر ان كان هناك في الاردن
تحريرها ليس بفعلها في السخونه
من الاشياء ايران هكذا حوران هذا الجيش
بمساله واحده
النهب وهاي المشكله
يجب ان تعترف بذلك يا اخي غساله يعني هلا
هلا استاذ زين يعني المقاطعه صارت مسموحه
لا تفضل
معك تفضل رد على هذه الاسئله انا سالتك
سؤال في الحقيقه وحتى اكون منصفا ايضا
للمشاهد ااه استاذ غسان انا لما سالتك
سؤالا الا واجبت في منطقه اخرى فانت الذي
تاخذ الحواله اخرى ولست انا في الواقع ركز
على تركز على اسئله انا اجيبك عليها اكثر
من مره وتعيد سؤال نفسه لانك تريد ان تقول
وان تحمل يعني كذلك بان تحمل الدوله
السوريه مسؤوليه كل ما يحصل انا ذكرت لك
حقائق كثيره فانا اقول لو كانت لو كان لو
كان اي نظام اي نظام يعمل على بنفس
الكفاءه التي يعمل بها في مجال الامن
ومجال همم الحفاظ على النظام نفسه لو كان
يعمل بنفس الكفاءه ليس فقط في سوريا ولكن
في كل بلدان الاستبداد في العالم بنفس
الكفاء على توفير قوت الناس لربما صادفه
النجاح لانه سيكون يعمل يعني عملا سيئا
واخر صالحا فربما يصادفه النجاح على هذا
العمل الصالح
يا استاذ زين اعطيني وقت لجاوبك بس رجاء
لا تقاطعني
الدوله السوريه كانت موجوده قبل 2011
وكانت الناس تعيش في بحبوحه وكانت يعني كل
شخص حتى الموظف كان ياخذ قرض من البنك
العقاري ويشتري بيت ويشتري سياره وكان
الدولار ب 46 ليره سوريه ولا يعني الذي
تغير هو ان يعني كل دول العالم تكالبت
علينا وارسل لنا حواليه 140,000 مقاتل
وجميع المنظمات الارهابيه ولاحظ اليوم
يعني هم لا يريدون ان يعيدها هؤلاء
المقاتلون الاجانب الى دولتهم الذين قتلوا
وقطعوا الرؤوس في الدوله السوريه لماذا
لانهم يريدون ان تستمر هذه الازمه ترامب
عندما انسحب من سوريا وكان يريد قال نحن
همم نحتفظ بحقول النفط وهذا مسجل وموجود
في احاديث همم ترامب عندما كانت ترامب في
الحمله الانتخابيه ماذا قال ان داعش وهذه
للدكتور يحيى قال زي فاونديد هو قال ان
اداره اوباما وكليتون هم الذين اسسوا داعش
وعندما اصبح في الحكم قال سنحتفظ به
النخبه اذا اليوم التناقض موجود في
الاداره الامريكيه والحقوبات الامري
يوجد كفاءه في الامن لكن لا يوجد كفاءه في
توفير الغذاء لكن ما علاقه كل ذلك
مخدرات في العالم ما علاقه المخدرات
بالموضوع
خليني اجاوبك على شغلك
الموضوع
يجب ان يكون هناك نوع من الموضوعيه او
الحياديه اذا انا ذكرت لك انه كانت سوريا
تنتج ثلاثه مليون طن من القمح واليوم تسرق
هذه الاقماع هذا لم تاخذ به ذكرني ان
اعترض عليه
لم اعترض على ما قلت لكن فيما يتعلق
بالمخدرات
طيب اذا كانت الدوله انتظرني بس دقيقه في
2018 14 نيسان قامت كل من فرنسا وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده باتهام الدوله السوريه
باستخدام الكيماوي في دومه وقاموا بتنفيذ
عمليه ثلاثيه سمي العدوان الثلاثي وانت
مصري وانتم تعرضتم للعدوان الثلاثي لم
ينتظر التحقيقات لم ينتظروا اللجنه
التحقيق الكيماوي لان ننتظر الامم المتحده
قاموا بضرب سوريا هل هذا كان على ادله
ايضا يعني ما تتهم به الدوله السوريه سواء
الكيماوي محمد حسنين هيكل رحمه الله قبل
ان يموت قال بان الغاز الذي
استخدم في سوريا كان من تركيا وبانه هو
الذي سرر يعني الكيماوي الى سوريا واعطاه
اجابه النصره التي تستخدم هذه المعارضه
ولا تاخذ به ال يعني الاعلاميون
سوريا سوريا
تقوله
دكتور يحيى العريضي في عجاله هذا لانه لم
يعد لدينا وقت اعطيتك الوقت الكافي يا
استاذ غسان دكتور يحيى العريفي نختم معك
همم رد على على سريع على ما يقوله ضيفنا
انه لا توجد ادله على ان سوريا في الواقع
هي اكبر مركز لتجاره المخدرات في العالم
[موسيقى]
روسيا وامريكا واسرائيل هي التي سحبت
السلاح القتل وابقت على هذه المنظومه هذا
من جانب همم بالنسبه للكبسه جوه والمخدرات
اساسها ايراني
والنظام لا حول ولا قوه له الا هذه الخاص
بهذه الاجرام هي التي تريد ان تعمل ايران
التي تريد ان تعمل نحيفها وتاخذ هذا
النظام كاداه مستبيحه كل شيء
والاقتصاد وشعره بانه من خلال ان ياته
وفجاعه بانه همم يمكن ان يستفيد موارد
معينه
لخاصيته ومن هنا عمليا استمر بهذا الموضوع
استمر بموضوع الكيميائي اقول بخير ختاما
استاذ زين اعتقد ان النجاه الوحيده
بالنسبه للسوريين وعوده بلدهم الى الحياه
لا يمكن ان تكون مع استمرار هذه المنظومه
الاستبداديه لان عندما نفكر بامريكا
وعندما تقول نريد فقط تغير سلوك النظام
نعرف تماما ان كل ذلك زائفا الذي اسلقه من
يقول النظام على كل حال نريد ان بلد الشعب
السوري وليس همم الدوله السوريه وليس
تنتهي الشعب السوري الذي يعيش في هذه
البقعه الجغرافيه والذي يتحمل المتحده
مسؤوليه معاقبته وانا اقول لك اي حصار واي
عقوبات هي تستهدف الشعب ولا تستهدف الدوله
فعلا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا ليبيا
للاسف اغسال يوسف من دمشق الكاتب الصحفي
واشهر الدكتور يحيى العريضي الاكاديمي
السوري ممتاز
اتمنى لكم تحيه مني زين العابدين توفيق
فيصل القاسم عوده الاسبوع
[موسيقى]